do you prefer tabs or spaces tabs tabs
why is that is there a reason for it or
is it just history less typing tabs or
spaces spaces why is that there good
reasoning for it so
[Music]
I'd be a tab person personally yeah but
then you get some editors that convert
tabs to spaces so doesn't really make a
difference
oh you get your tabs man so okay but now
to be fair so in people say people
answer whatever the answer is the answer
it would like as if light as if there's
ever a question what's the deal with
this contention
okay so practically speaking these days
if your text editor is good which like
they almost all are it's fine
the system will see whatever's in there
and you can convert between them
losslessly and it's actually not an
issue at all yes perfect I mean if you
go for spaces you need to go one two
three to get the same thing right it's
no way we'll use spaces for them for
programming
I think tabs is the way to go because
tabs semantically mean indentation like
that's what tabs are for as a character
and it also gives you the freedom to
decide how you if you like to view your
code with four or three or two or
whatever you can set your like tab stop
in your editor and it's fine but yeah
like I say these days if you if you feel
like doing that you can do that in your
editor even if it's done with spaces so
it kind of doesn't really matter anymore
but I feel like oh and also file sizes
right if you indent with tabs your files
are smaller spaces all TAS definitely
tabs why there are so what literally no
reason other than it makes more sense to
have a single character to me okay the
single character okay but how does it um
rendered though when somebody looks at
it there's kind of like X is it several
is it carries over I think so I don't
know I've never googled last ICU
question but
something I always wondered you know
because some you put it in like tabbing
and some very basic entities just just
Masons right and then I think that's the
editor though that just does that
automatically transfers I just so I can
check the mics work Andy what's your
preference is it tabs or spaces tabs
definitely tabs all the way I think it's
less presses of a button isn't it tabs
obviously obviously yeah and I just
press a button hope for the best tabs
all the way anywhere does use faces well
I don't understand the difference so why
why would you prefer whatever you know
so the reason why I say tabs and this is
probably because I'm a come from a
digital publishing document engineering
background this is it if you put a tab
when you're encoding to the computer
that you want to tabulate this to a
particular point whereas if you put
spaces in you're actually saying I want
these many spaces between it the
advantage of the tab is that if you've
got good software is that you could then
change the layout to meet the person
who's editing the code at that point
time rather than how forcing it to be
whatever weird standard you're using
tabs or spaces tons of spaces that's a
difficult one isn't it I saw used to use
tabs and only tabs and then I used PI
for a lot and actually I did a computer
file where I committed some code to
github that had only tabs and someone
just put in a pull request way to change
you back to spaces and I started
learning after that that maybe I should
just use spaces I'm going to use Python
that's all I use both
so both isn't I'm not sure that's
acceptable answer Bert okay we're taking
all right well yeah okay if I was to
choose house did you have a view on tabs
or spaces tabs any particular reason
it looks better to me it looks I like my
things spaced so I so I can I get lost
in clutter very easily so I put a lot of
space and tab is easier than place press
in space like six or seven times it's
just faster so
fact before before we start I think I
don't know if I've asked you my new
soundcheck question so let me give it a
go
tabs or spaces tabs or spaces are I need
notice of that question shot oh that's
it oh no no mm is it that you don't want
to answer that you know I can just think
of times when I would not trust the
tapping mechanism or for whatever I do
but equally there's other things where I
do trust is tapping mechanism to do what
I want to do and I would do that so the
answer is it depends
I'm sorry can't give you a better answer
the thing for me was what difference
does it make as you say it depends on
the tabie mechanism right well the point
is that when you tab you move to a fixed
point in it doesn't matter where you are
coming from you move to the next term
the danger with always using spaces is
sometimes you have to know how many
spaces to add to where you are to get
where the physical equivalent is to the
tab point whereas tab is such a nice
shortcut I don't know where the heck I
am on this line but I want the next tab
and I think that must be something to do
with a reason tabs or spaces or tabs
oh you've asked this one before although
I would like to change my answer okay
last time I think I said spaces but I
don't actually worry about it I just let
my text those that deal with it well I
think if the text if you ended if it's
already in the indented with tabs then I
just use the tabs
he makes obviously
favorite shortcut key the Vulcan nerve
pinch it does it it does they're both
the same oh okay
Windows desktop you know we can do
really anything with it it's yeah it's
pretty amazing
I don't know about favorite they all
have their pros and cons